you
[Music]
it's my great pleasure to have Rodrigo
Costello from University of Buenos Aires
visiting us he's a PhD student there and
working on making model checkers more
accessible to users and look forward to
the talk Thanks
thank you for the introduction Xu ven do
and again I'm gonna be talking about
well explaining inconclusive outcomes
from software model checkers to users
and this will mostly cover my PhD work
and it will extend a little bit into the
future with stuff that I would look
forward to do in the next few months
last years so let's start with
motivation so why do I want to care
about inconclusive model checker results
well because I might want to check any
of the properties that you have on your
right and we have assertions in the code
and we have asserting the assertions of
invariants and it's just regular C code
we'd have we're not dealing with models
we're actually dealing with source code
and I might choose a self Amal checker
that I like I might choose a set time
limit that I have maybe it's like one
minute maybe it's 15 minutes half an
hour whatever time I run my software
mall checker and then I come back and I
get unknown time limit exceeded or maybe
a memory limit exceeded or maybe I had
an abstraction refine an error or any of
those things or maybe I'm using a
bounded model checker and I get well I
didn't find a bug but I've reached the
bound so it's still an unsound result so
what do I get from this this is not a
really useful result because what are
you next do I extend the time limit do I
trust the code can I trust the code can
I just like commit this code like that
doesn't have any tests and just use it
like this should I change the technique
it's not really useful right so I feel
like this is a topic that actually
requires attention and I think it could
have an impact and we're going to talk
about how it could have an impact so
let's take a step back so we have
basically two ways of seeing
verification slash bug finding right so
we have bug finding techniques such as
bounded mall checking fussing the
dynamic symbolic execution and all that
and basically the workflow is you test
your system until basic
you've tested enough and you you assume
that your system works right you put it
on production it runs and then plus it
has bugs in test bugs but then you have
the opposite sort of and obviously
usually these the type of systems that
are tackled by each of these techniques
are different right that's why you also
have different baselines so if you're
working with assisted or automatic
verification but you're you're trying to
have full verification maybe your
baseline is well my program might have
bugs unless I find a full proof that the
program is safe right so what you do is
tempura fication and maybe you timeout
or you get some some counter example
that spears and then you simplify the
property and then you simplify the
program or refine the abstraction
essentially you work on the instance of
reification then you try again and if
you can't manage to get a conclusive
result then you basically assume that
your program is not safe because you
don't have any guarantee so you don't
know how far your small checker went
right so both of these approaches have
sorry yeah if your I mean if you I mean
so if you're working with for instance
Daphne right and you you have to add
invariance and whatever and you cannot
you get a timeout and stuff like that
well you're trying to simplify your
properties and maybe just look under the
hood why is it timing out and then you
split your properties and then maybe
that invariants and so on and so forth
but unless you have a fool proof you
won't say okay well I've tried good and
I mean I've tried for like maybe two
hours this must be good right usually
you don't do that that's I mean there's
not the work for that most people fall
maybe is that the process you described
no not really what I'm saying is that
you're trying yeah so what I'm saying is
that usually if you're an expert user
you will have some insight as to
what you're supposed to do but unless
you reach a foolproof
you won't assume that your program is
safe you won't you won't get halfway
through the proof and be like and I mean
I'm pretty sure this works usually when
you think that you you won't assume your
program works right so I think is you
have a property and a program you're
trying to prove this right yeah so so if
it's timing out the Assumption right the
user assumption is like that's right
yeah so I know but I don't know I mean I
might have all the information all the
information might be present it's just
like the theorem provers not good enough
to do it right now I have to do this
right so so what would you assume about
the system is sort of my my questions
would you assume that the program is
safety is would you release it into
production without a full proof do you
have any notion of how far you got yes
what about the case where I you know I
there's a property that I know holds as
a program right no that property holds
and I was just yeah and it can't prove
that property but I could just assert
the property is true I'm gonna say no
way the proof would go through but you
know assuming that it doesn't timeout
for some reason which you know that
that's all different category at issue
but but but the point is I think you
know the human can get in the loop in
the sense that you can help help with
the proof of theorem provers by giving
it sort of extra information that the
printer has but the you know the
verification system does it those are
done he means by simplify the property
right so we having an assumption would
supersize money no we're really simple
yeah okay okay so but then at that point
then why would it why would you stop in
some sense because he could always give
it an unfair formation - yeah the
question is at some point maybe you
think that it probably holds but you're
not absolutely sure I mean if you if you
know that appropriate holds you
definitely add it to your assumption I
mean and then you have a conclusive
refutation result but if you don't if
you don't reach that point if you keep
iterating on this and you're like okay
I'm adding assumptions that I'm not
really sure hold right now because I
don't really know what this library does
or like this other thing then maybe you
want to know well are my assumptions too
strong like when does this assumption
actually affect me like is this relevant
to my system or not right
so problems well bug finding and testing
doesn't really have that many guarantees
cuz I mean your testing so if you didn't
find bug you don't know whether there
exists one or not well you have it yeah
if you well if you find one yeah but if
you haven't fallen you don't have many
guarantees and the problem with the
other approach is that well it's kind of
all or nothing if you if you followed
that idea that paradigm off okay if I
don't have a foolproof then I'm not
gonna give up then it's kind of are of
nothing right if you didn't manage to
make the whole proof of the effort that
you spin on it is wasted and you have to
start over with whatever other technique
you you're gonna use and then to be
honest there's not that many people
using this sort of techniques right in
industry basically testing is way more
widespread than verification formal
verification techniques in in the sense
of trying to achieve a full proof so
what if we stick if we take a different
perspective right and we use this sort
of verification tools but we use them in
a way as okay this could be better than
testing but but I want to know how good
it was right and let's assume that a
visual studio checked every search in
memory safety and I'm doing a little bit
of science fiction here right but it's
supposed it checks off this properties
system API specs then we have a
dashboard showing us how good the
verification attempt was right so we
have maybe on the Left the things that
were probably checked that we got a
complete safe result and we have a proof
that it holds then have them the right
maybe the warnings and we could have
different kinds of warnings we could
have warnings that might be false
positives and then they can be ranked
according to how how likely it is that
it's a false positive or or that it's a
true positive and then in the middle we
have sort of an explanation of what your
malla checker did right what sort of
behaviors it cover what part of the code
did you cover do you have like any like
code coverage things and maybe suppose
this is all integrated into the code
review process and instead of asking
your your developer okay
whenever you check in code I wanted to
test your code maybe you have a separate
dashboard that goes okay well this was
tested in the backend the Nasher and all
of these parts of the code were actually
tested and the parts of the code that
we're not are this edge cases
maybe that would be that would kind of
change how we use verification tools
right and okay I said it was doing a
little bit of science fiction but
honestly what parts of this are not
present yet we already we can already
check all of these assertions and if it
it is fully verified that's the column
on the left we can show that right and
then we have we can definitely produce
warnings we can produce writings with
different levels of guarantees and we
also rank them that's we have Angelica
verification we have almost rag
specifications and all that allows us to
rank different warnings right but we
don't have this stuff in the middle we
don't really explain what happened in
the cases when we don't have a warning
but we don't have a foolproof and that's
a lot of cases so maybe if we had that
and just maybe that might be the one
element that keeps off the rest things
together and makes it reasonable to
integrate it into a mainstream ID like a
visual visual studio right they give you
a combined effort it could be a combined
effort of maybe you're testing plus
whatever of reification efforts you have
but essentially you would have an idea
of what parts of the code were not
actually exercise what parts of the of
the system behaviors are not checked yet
it's okay this was a little bit of
wandering around in my mind but let's
talk about how my work my PhD work fits
into what already exists and how is that
step forward or not and okay let's start
with with two papers that are actually
from my my research group the first one
my-mult record died how well does it do
what it does is basically it gives you a
measure oh it gives you them pretty much
that's what you're asking
yeah so it gives you a measure approval
a signature why is that because it
tackles probabilistic model checking of
Markov chains right and what it asks for
the user is the usage profile so you
need to give it some idea of how the
system is used so that it can tell you
well if that's the probabilistic
distribution of methis or input or
whatever then this is how much of the
state space you have explored so that's
asking a little bit too much of a suffer
/ but also the this does not really
scale that well to solve for multiple
source code besides its super sensitive
to those usage profiles that you provide
so it's not ideal there's definitely
room for improvement then Allah + hot
core and Allah Allah is a specification
language that is specifically suited
suitable for structural properties so
it's good to specify maybe data
structure and variants and the way it
works is it bounce the the constraints
and then it translates them into
propositional logic and then it checks
in with a Sat solver
and the idea behind this paper is
essentially okay let's let's try to get
some statistics on on which variables
and clauses are involved and involved in
most conflicts and lift that up and show
it to the user so that the user can pay
attention to those and maybe organize
them in a different way so it's kind of
heuristic and it's limited to alloy it
doesn't necessarily apply to other types
of techniques and languages alright this
is part of the stuff that we're building
on and then the most related work is
basically conditional model checking
which I work on top off basically
and then explicit assumptions which you
probably know because you had Maricruz
jackets here this is I think the
original paper was collaborative
verification and testing with explicit
assumptions or something like that and
then bounded up to the interpretation
which I'm not going to mention much but
it's basically builds on top of explicit
assumptions and let's talk about
conditional model checking a little bit
so we have this example right and the
true branch of the code can be easily
proved safe using some sort of predicate
abstraction why is that because we don't
need to sort of unroll the loop too many
times right if we we track the predicate
is greater than or equal to a million
then it's easy to prove that the true
branch is correct however if you if
we're using predicate abstraction the
nonlinear condition on the false branch
of the F might be hard proof right so
your model checker might give up right
so what they propose is okay it would be
good if that failed attempt could sort
of give some of that knowledge forward
to whatever its subsequent
replication attempt right so they what
they proposed is instead of having mall
taking have three possible results true
it means that the property holds false
means the that there's a counter example
and it produces it and then unknown
maybe we can only have false and then
true under a certain condition that's
their general idea right so that
subsequent of replication attempts can
use that condition to serve constrained
or state space yeah that's right so
that's the general approach now they
instantiate that for a particular kind
of analysis and that's abstract
reachability trees and what they produce
their condition is an assumption
automaton right and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about assumption I want and
observability trees in the next few
slides because it's relevant for my work
but let's just look at this example for
a second because it's it's I think it's
really easy to follow it what's going on
so we have an edge that goes from the
from the root node to the node labeled
true right and that edge is labeled by
the condition
none debt basically holds so that means
if you enter the den branch of the code
then you're safe the truth the true node
may means that all of that portion of
the state space has been verified so
every subsequent analysis does not need
to check that so this is useful because
maybe you're using explicit value
analysis afterwards and then that would
get stuck in the loop if you if you
didn't if you couldn't discard that
whole state space so that's an
interesting idea
right so that's basically their use case
and and how they show that it could be
useful and now let me explain a little
bit how absurd mutability trees work and
what they are it's just the false branch
yeah yeah yeah so the else branch is
sort of unrolled in a way because it
couldn't manage to so the thing is the
molecule had had trouble getting rid of
the spurious counter example right so it
has a nonlinear condition it has sorry
it has an assertion that says that our
is greater or equal to X and X R is X
square so it's it's always gonna hold
but since it's nonlinear it might have
some trouble getting rid of that color
example right so what it does is when it
cannot refine the instruction it gives
up and it gives up telling you well I
explored everything but I have this part
of the state space that I haven't
explored because I couldn't get rid of
it basically it means that it hasn't
that part of the state space is not
being explored
I'm gonna explain this in a little bit
more detail after I explain that's what
utility treats its otherwise it's kind
of hard fall but one of the kind of
situations where you know you have that
kind of result and they is there
literature that says it's a common part
of it yeah all right in the paper they
have a they have an evaluation with SP
comp instances I don't know if that
happens a lot in practice but then again
in serve a chicken-and-egg problem like
we don't really use verification that
often in practice and then as we can if
you had this yeah that verifications
help you part of the code but that may
be so that every benefit people almost
over there so so that mean verification
generally doesn't work because otherwise
you want to how many of our support
there are very complex and you just show
lots of false alarms that part of the
code so basically if I think of it
abstractly I can have a whole set of
different analyses and and the abstract
reach ability tree lets me basically say
what this analysis was able to prove
true and then where it gave a saccas in
table because of whatever imprecision it
could be an to be imprecision in the
abstract oh man it could be a timeout I
mean it could be but whatever it is you
can sort of summarize the state space of
what was explored and prove trip mmm and
then the rest yeah that's right so
that's the idea didn't you take this
thing and you can pass it on yeah it's a
rep
station this thing made me huge I mean
the rubbish name is huge
yes I mean like we did this in Slam
right we had the model checker we have a
biddies and yeah we could persist the
BVDs
but somehow we never really did that for
some reason yeah I mean we learned a lot
to the state space but yeah I mean these
things these yeah okay yeah I agree it
is definitely huge but anyway so that's
their use case and that's how they show
that it could be useful and absolutely
decrease basically you probably are
familiar with it but I'll just go over
it quickly it's just to make it
self-contained our trees that we're its
notes correspond to state in the country
floating on top of the code and its
edges are labeled with statements and
the way it works is it keeps it keeps a
wait list of notes that haven't been
explored yet so these are the ones in
orange that have the big arrows that say
unexplored then you pop a note from the
wait list and then you add its
successors to the wait list basically
that's what it does all the time until
it finds the target note right so in
this case the red the red node the node
seven it's a it's an error note the
thing is it's an unfeasible or note and
why is that well because the path that
it takes is well it assigns I signed
five to I then it checks whether I is
greater than zero and it goes on the
false side of the condition and that
cannot happen because five is greater
than zero so that's the reason why it's
not feasible then it goes on and then it
reaches the air condition so what do we
do we associate to that to that note in
the astral reachability tree a predicate
why is that well because absolute
reachability treat notes are associated
with an element of an abstract domain
that sort of makes them versatile but if
we had for instance blast is based on
after visuality trees and their domain
is the predicates right so we add that
that predicate and what happens next
well that defines implicitly a reach
ability region right so we will be able
to get get the whole subtree that hangs
from node four and remove it right
because we know that the predicate no
the eye is not greater than zero there's
not hold under the
- right so we remove that what do we get
we get this right so we only get the N
export note 3 in the wait list and then
we pop it and then we added successors
and we have another note and then we pop
it and so on so if we're finished right
now and we timed out then our assumption
of talent on would look pretty much like
this but without the the predicate and
the note - right because some Shinra
tanta only exposes the structure but not
the domain elements so basically that's
an overview of conditional while
checking and that's reversibility trees
now let's go with explicit assumption so
what they do is propose an extension to
the to the specification language that
was such that we have something that
behaves a lot like assume statements are
in the full in the full app
serviceability but you're building it on
the fly so yeah that's right rest
several you mean the rest it's not the
complement of what you verify hmm not
really compared well I mean I mean it
will represent so basically the the
property of the attribute ability tree
is that every system execution will
either every feasible system execution
will either lead to a node in the wait
list or it will lead to into a true node
basically that would be the property of
the SMT no tonton that you produce so
it's an over approximation in that sense
then I have explicit assumptions and
what what's the use case that a
Christakis had in mind basically it's a
good way of annotating what unsound and
assumptions were made during
purification so one example when good
example is that there's no integer
overflow right we have unbounded
integers so it's pretty clear like if
you if you're reading if you were seeing
daphne and then you get you get this
assumed statement your you might realize
so what wait in the language that I'm
trying to model maybe I do have integer
overflow so I might need to pay
attention to this this is these
annotations are really useful for local
assumptions they're maybe not that great
for the type of
that you make that you want to capture
in conditional and not in Assumption
automata right why is that well because
for instance when you have Lupin rolling
and they actually check this in in their
paper and the explicit assumptions paper
it's kind of hard to express this it's
actually impossible to express it just
with the assumed statements so what they
do is they have to transform the loop so
you have to transform the code in order
to add these assumptions but then again
I feel like there's room for improvement
right so it's what we were talking about
before you add an assumption that you
might not be sure whether it holds or
not and it might be buried deep inside
your code and some obscure function that
you sometimes call and you wonder well
when are these assumptions broken when
do they hold does is it relevant that I
added this assumption is it not relevant
anyway so yeah so some some sauces what
they do is they unroll the loop once and
they assume that the second time you
don't enter basically so it's bounded
more checking it's once basically with
the one iteration right but if you want
to do this for more than why tration
then you have to unroll it in the code
and that's I mean that's not ideal I
think that makes it way less
understandable so there's definitely
room for improvement here right because
you don't know how relevant these
assumptions are and then the same thing
happens with conditional watching let's
go back to what we said before you asked
me well what does it mean that you have
a false state here what means that you
sorry yeah no they are yeah so that's
one other studies that they did was
basically checking out what how relevant
this assumptions is in sound assumptions
were aggressive in the model triggers
which is part of the soundness manifesto
paper and so on alright so back to
conditional politicking
that well is this a perfect solution
well the thing is suppose you exposed
this to a user well first of all yeah
it's gonna be huge which is what Tom
mentioned but other than that you see a
false statement and you might be
wondering well how relevant is that
false
well it's not really relevant because
it's not reachable there right so you
need to do something about it in order
to interpret it so basically this is
where we start from so what is my
approach well have two different
approaches one of them is execution
reports so what we do is we we present a
report that captures safety assurances
in terms of system executions and in
their relationship to the safety
property of interest right and then we
have another approach which is coverage
which is sort of the opposite yeah
meanwhile while executing reports aim
for detail coverage aims for six Antonis
right and we it is an intuitive
definition it's comparable to test with
coverage which is interesting because
you get a way to compare two different
techniques but they're kind of compliant
so let's let's start with execution
reports so as I mentioned what you do is
you you create a report based on system
executions and can quickly what we do is
we provide two sets of system executions
one is the exploration frontier and the
other one are the safe guns essentially
if you've if you've already fold the
whole part about a conditional model
checking what we try to find is paths
that are feasible that lead to the safe
the the true States and the false States
and what does it mean for for an
execution to be in the exploration
frontier let's look at the example on
the Left we have a verification harness
that exercises the operation to
operations of a stack we have push and
pop and then it non-deterministically
chooses the operation it calls the
function and then it checks whether the
invariant holds right and does that
forever basically
so what does it mean to have the
execution push-push in the in the
exploration frontier what it means is
that that's the precise point where the
analysis gave up right so when it was
reaching the second push call it had to
stop for whatever reason timeout or
anything and then it didn't explore it
that system execution but it didn't
explore any of its continuations right
any any possible extension of it and the
same holds for push Bob right so if you
had to
if you just just finished your mala
ticking attempt and you left it for half
an hour will you be like okay it's ready
to go to production maybe you wouldn't
right because you're like ah you didn't
check any of the border conditions that
I might be interested in
alright so this is I mean it's not great
because you still have to do something
you have to test your system or
something but at least you know that
your mala ticking attempt was definitely
not good enough and what might happen to
you if you're using for instance in
Malta a bonded multicam technique is
that well you get the idea that okay it
didn't present you any warnings but it
didn't really go that far because
whatever it couldn't skip some loop or
something like that anyway well that's a
great question and actually it's not but
I mean the depends it depends on what
instances you're you're looking at it -
so traces I mean it seems like it seems
like others when you you're trying to
you're trying to sort of summarize an
exploration which inherently you know
the program besides that this can be
this can be exponential in that's right
right so it's I can do about that a
little bit yeah question you know I
guess we found a model checking the
underlying assumption is that with you
know even a small like if you're doing
concurrency or something like even with
a small number of threads you're gonna
find bugs yeah you know you're not gonna
find the bugs when there's 16 threads
because it's way too far but but even
but the whole point of stopping is that
you know if you keep going it's gonna
give you a state space we can pick
bigger and bigger but right and you and
so it seems like this frontier that
you're talking about would be we just
get you know exponentially larger it's
like Thomas hanging and what would a
person do with that at that point that's
gonna true it let me let me talk about
that first and then I'll take about
tom-toms observation so first of all the
thing is with bond dibala checking is
that you have that assumption but it's a
very general assumption so one of the
things that inspirated me actually to
start doing all this it's that i did an
internship
here and I was using Corral and one of
the things that I kept doing all the
time was adding false assertions to know
how far my my exploration attempt went
and I was like I mean yeah it's true
that yeah shallow box and all that but I
mean how far did it go like did I get
after the initialization loop can you
prove this false false and I would I
would spring those herd faults after
certain loops because I was like I mean
I know like how you can't even get here
but I mean I mean I'm not the type of
super novice user still I had to do some
really kind of dark stuff to make sure
that that the Moloch was doing some of
what I wanted it to do right yeah okay
so I mean it's true it's true but it's
still we need like we need a list a tiny
window into what's going on because the
statement at least we didn't you can say
just like it does because it's
fundamentally executing we're gonna talk
about coverage in the couple slides
instead of traces that's right okay and
your your your question was actually
really good so you might have an
explanation number traces that's true
one other thing is we don't we don't say
that we're gonna present the whole set
of traces we say that we're gonna
present some and why is that important
well first of all because if you see one
trace that is too short you might
already realize that your expression is
not deep enough those are other things
and then your other question was well
you might have a ton of traces that are
very similar why is that well because
inside the push you might have an if
whatever condition happens then and you
have one path that goes on the to
condition and then another passed
because of the false condition
well that's so that's true and that's a
problem that we actually don't tackle
explicitly in our paper I did tackle it
in order to look at the output and what
I do is basically I group those traces
what I look at is for instance in this
case API operations right so it's true
that I don't get the full I don't get
the full detail but if I know that I
didn't do more than two loop iterations
of the main loop
we would probably agree that does not a
very deep exploration well for none of
the examples that I checked in the ESB
comp benchmark I had never reached the
third iteration of loop right so it does
actually happen that you don't really
get that far and it really depends on
how non-deterministic your instances and
so forth
but it's not entirely crazy to have
businesses cover that actual yeah then
you know carry because they might
suppose put these traces on there that's
right yeah but that's okay you still
know that you never cover up your two
pushers that's right yeah yeah that's I
mean that's the sort of insight that we
want to get and then we have safe cones
and what are safe cones well this is
essentially passed to the to the
collapse part of the Assumption
otamatone right so this is the true
notes it's those places where you
managed to prove that something was safe
and let's see it with an example again
so we have a verification harness on the
left that non-deterministically chooses
the mode of operation of a system right
and we have mode 1 and mode 2 and our
original verification result would be
unknown Tim only to exceed it or some
like that what we get now is well the
system execution that only calls mode 1
is the safe trace what does that mean
well it means that your system is safe
to use under moat 1 because any
extension of it will also be safe that
means that there's no assertion failure
that's a very strong statement that's
much better than what you would get with
testing and much better than what you
would get with an unknown result right
but it's also detailed enough to tell
you that well even though mode 1 has
been very successfully proved safe then
mode 2 is not so good right because we
get pretty much the same case that we
got before we didn't get past the first
iteration of the while loop so it gives
you some insight into well maybe you can
remove mode 1 from your verification
harness and then maybe you can pay
attention to mode 2 and probably use
another technique because you're not
making progress with this right this is
a very manual though I didn't made that
it's not like we're gonna get a tool
working right away sorry
that's right yeah yeah so we're not
going to go over each of these formulas
right now but what I want to emphasize
is that part of the work is that we
formalize what the guarantees for each
of these parts of the output are and
what are the connections between our
output and the safety guarantees because
I think that's relevant for making it
intuitive and understandable but what we
are going to do is go over these
formulas and how they apply to the
previous examples right so we have the
first example in which we saw the
exploration frontier and what does it
mean that we have push push in the
exploration frontier well it means a
that it's feasible right it's an actual
system execution you don't have to go
checking well can I actually ever do to
push this in a row no we actually
checked that for you because that's the
reasonable thing to do but then we also
know that whatever safety property you
were checking for holds right that means
that your analysis is sound if there was
a bug in that trace we would have found
it and then you know basically the same
thing that you would know for tests case
right if you see a test case that passes
you know that well it didn't fail which
is kind of intuitive but still and then
you get that it's a maximal right so
that's the exact point where the the
mall checkers stopped analyzing so you
know that that's basically where the
frontier reached it's not like well you
might be exaggerating or it might be
more than what it actually reached no
that's the exact point where things
change from being analysed to not being
analyzed and that can give you an
insight if you know sort of something
about the technique the underlying
technique and what about the safe cones
well safe codes it's pretty much the
same thing we have there feasible so
actually you can use mode one is not
impossible to use it and and then it's
minimal so it's the strongest guarantee
that you can have and also while it is a
cone in the sense that we have the
property of traces the safe cone any
extension is a safe cone which is one
over here and well if it's the safe gun
it's feasible then the probably holds
right that's basically it so yeah
so like what's the diffusion that if you
do more one you're guaranteed all
extensions are safe
yeah what what does it correspond to
really even in a verification instance
it would be pretty much the example that
we had at the beginning that we have if
some so basically if you have if you
have some some weird optimization in
some in your mode of operation and that
makes it super hard to model check it
whereas the other one is straightforward
but is just a super inefficient maybe it
would be easier to check that's sort of
the motivation obviously chicken an egg
we don't really have big verification
instances to do not check manually and
so on so well anyway so what are the
research questions first is this yeah
sorry that's right it's pretty similar
it's the difference is that the goal of
this is to show it to to user and
basically in in the case of microseconds
just writing tests and maybe you would
have to look at the tests that would be
your goal it's kind of related it's to
suffering kind of a Liza's also the the
type of annotations that she has works
for specific kind of techniques it
doesn't really work for the same
techniques that I'm trying to tackle so
I mean it's complementary she was using
Daphne she was just not using like coal
program mothers or she was using modular
stuff so it's I mean it's a it's a
slightly different use case basically so
research questions well is this a
practical performance right so as you
might be a picture already what do we
have - what we have now is several
verification tasks we came from one that
didn't work well and now we have several
because we need to produce several
counter examples right so this might
very well be know the answer to research
question one and then research question
two is kind of related to what you asked
before is this going to be an
exponential number of traces this is
going to be
by you sir ideally we would want to test
whether this is understandable and
useful I don't I have to be honest with
you we're not at this stage yet we don't
have a clear use case that we can
conduct a user study and be like okay
does this work better than what you had
before again to get an egg we're not
using gratification for anything so it's
kinda hard to tell
architecture so this is how sorry we
have been tried but we what like we
don't really know how to conduct a user
study that would be a realistic use case
that is so ready a use case because you
don't have any way to look into
verification results right now so you
can't really outperform that yeah well
we what we have is anecdotal evidence so
what if you what I do is I go and check
the output and say well you didn't know
this before but I don't know if that is
there's not a review per user study
that's a author study right so
conducting a user study means you have a
user and you don't really have users of
similar techniques right now that's kind
of the problem yeah I did
I went through every single okay and I'm
not gonna talk about the other study
because now that's not in the published
paper but I we can definitely talk about
it in the questions yeah so yeah so our
proxies is at least are they manageable
in size because if it's not then why
bother right so this is the architecture
you have a system under purification
you've run it through your cell from all
checker that's after we reach ability
tree based that produces the assumption
of otamatone which is the attribute
ability to a structure and the input for
the to verification tasks is the system
under verification and the rit structure
right and they're different and they're
independent in that they have different
targets right we and one we're targeting
the the states the nodes in the waitlist
which is the one that produces the
frontier the the expiration frontier and
then in the other one we're looking for
the collapsed true states in the
Assumption automata which are the safe
cones
that's why it
a little goofy so so you're doing three
model checking then you produce the art
and then you have another model checker
so that don't quite understand so yeah
let's go over again oh if you're if
you're applying the same model checker
to in art give you the model checker did
something yeah it gives you an art yeah
and then you ask it to explore more from
those states you ask it to explore it
yeah yura fication instance essentially
what it does is it composes the system
with the attribute ability treat yes I
understand
right and then you thought you make
queries the result of running the first
model trip basically yeah okay and then
you make queries on top of that and try
to see which of those states are
actually feasible or not because you're
interested in the true states and the
false states one one one detail about
this is it doesn't have to be the same
all checker for like this those three
boxes you're gonna be even the same any
new information yeah if those two are
the same right okay so this might be the
case of like Daphne and some other like
DSC like I might have different notions
of checking whatever the checking's you
don't have the art structure that
service no I mean reading the diagram
it's just if you're I'm just saying if
you're if you're if you give like the
end result
well maybe you give it more time and it
can just go is that it's not it's not
just about giving it more time it's a
different property so it's gonna be a
different exploration altogether because
you can have an effect you know
absolutely but but it's it's a different
structure you could trigger a different
abstraction refinements because that so
it's not the exact same exploration but
I do agree and there's actually results
in the evaluation day ok cool so you
could so the model checker might have
many different parameters then like the
second time you do it you might you
might tweak them yeah yeah right
absolutely sir picture
you're essentially creating the art
using these two markjenner you're asking
some properties in the art that's right
as opposed to just taking some property
that's right this is saying which part
is really that's right so what we do is
we run this on 68 instances from as we
come this are the instances that the
conditional mall ticker paper presented
so we I mean we should try to not have
any section advice on that and then we
use two techniques value.now Valley
analysis and Lacey predicative traction
which are very different in themselves
and that's kind of shown in that they
timeout for almost entirely different
instances and then phase one of the
evaluation is we run this with a 900
second time limit we run both techniques
and then for those instances that
produce inconclusive results we run
phase two and we generate execution
reports right with the same time limit
both techniques again so we have
basically first analysis in them valve
analysis or first of all you notice and
then predicate abstraction and so on is
it there's four combinations right it's
yeah yeah and okay what are the results
for this well we we get nine
inconclusive results with value analysis
in the first phase right we produce a
full and then full means something I'm
gonna explain what full means frontier
reports for five of those instances
using Lacey period analysis and the
average size is 12 point two ranging
from four to thirty it's not huge it's
manageable then of the extension voice
and then the number of executions in the
in the full frontier set yeah that's
right they're very long I'm gonna talk
about that in a second yeah and the
average time limit is well 78 seconds
it's that's kind of good right because
it's a it's less than 10% of the
original verification time the size in
terms of lines of code
it's about a thousand lines each it
might be somewhere a couple hundred
somewhere a little bit over a thousand
they're not huge yeah so yeah so that's
for volley analysis it's not it's not
great but it's for more than half of
them you can produce a report within a
fraction of the verification time right
so for volley analysis then we get the
safe component of the report we were
talking about different frontier
component now we're talking about the
safe component saying we only produce
four five curiously it's not the same
five so it's not like if you can produce
a full report for the for the instance
and here the average sized is slow right
it's just a one trace it so it goes from
Syria to it's like it's not much and
then the average time goes up
significantly it has to be less than the
original it's it's okay and then we want
to those that timed out with crank it on
us right and we get 16 inconclusive
results and we produced a full Vinci
report for 13 of those and curiously
again it works better using volley
analysis to produce the reports which is
what Tom had dan said about so the
average size in this case it's not that
good it's 120 118 point three traces
that's not what I would describe as
manageable right that's a little too
high but I notice you keep track of the
values of the of the properties of the
values of the variables so that your
printer gets our equality oh so you do a
lot of you do a lot of room rolling
basically because you're gonna have a
different note for each iteration of the
loop usually because you increment about
the value and then you have a different
note so yeah so every size goes up
average time still it's pretty
it's a 10% but it can go up to six
hundred twenty-nine seconds which is not
that low
so 13 out of 16 given that we're doing
several yeah the time so nine hundred
second stuff related cases okay yeah so
you can't go over that and that's what I
was saying no yeah yeah because you
that's if you only get five yeah
brilliant five go for failure for a new
producer for to introduce a full report
and I'm going to talk about that in a
second I'm sure I don't know where it
was a pretty good mouthful for tear here
save reports same 13 is not the same 13
though and again what works better is
value analysis right and the average
size in this case is not great it's zero
point zero seven so it means that for
those four twelve of those it was zero
it had in the there was no it means the
fraction of the
I mean my intuition is this is the
post-processing of the purification
dollar if I gotta give it five hours I
might as well give you the purification
time I realize so yeah I feel like
that's a I mean it's an arbitrary limit
yeah I just I wanted to see how
basically if it's more than the original
verification time I feel like it's no
use of producing a report that takes
longer than the oh that's standard for
as become so I just use that yeah yeah
you would you would might think well I
should I should give it ninety
nice just a little 10% yeah I mean
definitely that's that's a fair question
[Music]
I'd like more than four yeah oh sure we
does a complete yeah sure sure I I agree
that more than 900 seconds is a lot then
I don't know if maybe 90 would be right
maybe 15% would be right but I mean you
can you can see the paper and be like
okay maybe I think that that's not a
good evaluation of whether it's
performance no I mean it's just I'm not
gonna if I get an average of 900 seconds
I don't think it's really good all right
um so yeah we still get 13 the average
time is somewhat low it's 55 seconds so
yeah and then one of the things that is
cool about these reports well in my
opinion anyway is that you can get some
value of it by even seeing parts of it
you don't need to get the full report to
get information so if you see one trace
that tells you okay you didn't explore
more than the first iteration you know
that any extension of that trace is not
explored then you're maybe um this is
not really good right this is not a
really good expression and what I check
here is the time until the first element
of either the safe cones or the frontier
of the expression frontier is produced
and what we have here is the
combinations of different techniques
right so we have P stands for pretty
good analysis and E for explicit volley
analysis and then P P means that I ran
pretty good odds first and then I ran
breaking laws for the generation and so
on its forth and we get is that for most
instances we can produce we can produce
at race between fib starting within half
of the verification time well you can
also check it for like 10% is not great
but you can produce it for many
instances with some some of those some
of those combinations and then sort of
what are the results or the conclusion
self evaluation well the technique that
you use for the execution report
definitely affects the performance which
is what what Tom sort of had the
intuition even before I talked about it
and then the running time does not seem
prohibitive I mean we can disagree in
whether it's 10% 15% but it's not a
multi
of 28 times the verification times the
size of output an average is usually
fine but the maximum is definitely not
great what I do and in order to that's
kind of related to to my own inspection
of the of the output it's you can group
this traces and and sort of abstract
them the problem with that is the
semantics is not that clear then because
what it is it's a it's an existential
semantics on that abstraction so it
means that there's some concrete trace
that has been explored or has not been
explored and it's kind of fussy for an
end user but for the purpose of
analyzing your output is was actually
super useful I might write a paper about
it at some point I know anyway
definition of analyzed well that's
that's a problem with the safe cones
what what is the problem with the safe
cones
well if you look at at the assumption
automata sometimes what happens is that
trivially by just extending the
contraflow automaton from that place
there's no reachable assertion so those
are by by definition safe cones right
and and what we're using we're sort of
inheriting our definition of what is
analyzed is what we get as the output of
conditional mall checking so paying
attention to what has been analyzed is
part of explaining this in conclusive
results because it's not it's not really
trivial to do that I mean if you're if
you if you want to explain this to user
you might want to spend a little bit
more time making trivial extensions to
your to your exploration frontier
basically so yeah that's kind of a
conclusion and sort of future work yeah
if you do know what I'm saying is if you
do a really dumb post-processing on the
assumption otamatone you can get better
better results sorry so if useful to
understand kind of what this looks like
in concretely like you know I finally if
I see one of these traces yeah and also
a be useful that I actually understand
were there cases where the trace led you
to look at the code
understand why something was analyzable
yeah yeah absolutely so oh well why it
wasn't Iceland illa but what so let me
explain a little bit about that I was
hoping to talk about the in the
questions but let's talk about it now
okay so what I did and in the first
iteration of this paper was go over all
the of the outputs and and check what
insights gonna get from from what I was
producing right and the first problem
that you bump into is the traces are
huge so you can't you can't deal with
that so what do you do well you look at
the stack depth right because that gives
you an idea of like how far into you are
you're in right and you filter it some
of it because you don't really care
about it and you group them together
maybe have like 150 and I have five and
then you okay you look at this tub stack
that then you see that okay you have two
two methods that are get called in a
sequence now maybe there's a loop there
I didn't know they said I don't look it
as become code in my free time so I
didn't know the instances so what I did
it was okay you have you have a trace
and then okay let's look at the code
where does this method get called oh it
gets called in one place it's the main
loop of the program now what you see is
that your exploration frontier maybe
reaches the second iteration of the loop
but you got all of that understanding
from maybe alligator I had one trace and
think wrap on the code if you wanted me
to do that by looking at the attribute
ability tree and the code I don't know
if I could have done that that's what
I'm saying I think it gives you an
insight that you couldn't get from just
the raw materials basically but you
require you still require some post
processing to make it be manageable
because these are long traces this is
like it's cast every state in every
single statement to make the semantics
sort of clear in other words if you give
you the trace and I'm a developer
because the way I was thinking about it
too is you know you could you know you
can stop and give me this abstraction
and then I look at it and I use my brain
to understand what's going on but where
you I'll check your continue to run yeah
so my brain time is worth a lot more
than the CPU time absolutely but how far
will you get by giving it like twice as
much time that's exciting that we didn't
do and we should
this question about like you know what's
the what's the human process afterwards
right and how long is that take ya know
that's a fair question
I agree it's a fair question so the way
I envision it is you're asking well why
I've done just like let it run longer
the problem is that if you let it run
longer you're in the same position that
you were before which is what did it do
is it good enough or not right and use
my panniers but but yeah but let's
consider the comparison is bad you let
it run an hour you find something or it
doesn't or you give it to me and you can
be in comfort
yeah and with the question is well I
find errors in that hour right is what
you're giving to the human you know I've
been spending more time on Excel
spreadsheets it turns out but the point
is you know there is a sort of brainy
guy like my brain is doing something you
give me information and the question is
like can't we can't be heavy like that
instead of when you take that out but I
think the computer can understand your
outputs better than my brains the
questions how do you do that sometimes I
think the problem is that it's a it's a
fundamentally different task that's the
thing one thing is to go bug finding and
another one is to define whether
whatever attempt that you did was good
enough or not that's the problem so if
you're using for instance the static
driver verifier and you reach the
whatever about it iteration bound and
and you didn't find any bugs and you're
leading the company that does drivers
are with us Hardware whatever how do you
know if that's enough or not or if you
need more testing or engineering
absolutely yeah and that's kind of where
coverage definitely that that sort of
assumes that your user is an experienced
user which I'm trying not to because
that sort of limits my impact but yeah
yeah you can definitely do that
I think I mean fundamentally giving I
mean there's this but just giving
coverage information saying well I got
here is one extreme the other is you can
like say well have this program like I
learned this invariant and that
invariant might well you know might not
be parsimonious it might have all sorts
of variables that aren't relevant and
confuses the user but it might be
worthwhile persisting that the user
might get some insight oh you just
covered something interesting about my
code you know and that takes up a lot
more time than like inspecting a
coverage report oh you got here good or
you didn't get here soso I think I think
there's still like a spectrum of
information that the model checker has
and it's not exactly clear you know
there's there's a whole design space
there right because with predicate
abstraction you have these formulas over
the predicate you might have learned
interesting facts is it useful don't
know so yeah I mean I think the reach
ability tracer discards a lot of them
right I mean kind of it I think it
depends on what kind of analysis you're
you're using if you're using a utility
tree you're mostly not gonna yeah we can
talk about it later
yeah yeah so coverage so one of the
questions is okay you got that reporting
how do you know whether it's good enough
or not should I stop model checking or
not and well an obvious solution to that
is well everyone that sounds a lot like
adequacy right so what's verification
adequacy I don't know I didn't think you
guys know either but can we summarize
this execution reports is there any way
to do that and then it would be cool if
we got some of the users that use
coverage you know don't have that many
users so anyway one of the problems with
defining coverage and you might be like
okay I'll just like output whatever
statements they covered and one of the
problem is that what if you're doing
incremental search right so you're doing
loop unrolling or some like that and you
have this example right so if you this
has only one system execution right and
it always reaches assert false so
we have we have an application temp that
unrolls this loop rad for a number times
and it takes forever a nighttime out
right and what do I say about that
statement is it covered is it not and it
seems like a kind of trivial question as
well it doesn't really matter it's just
about a definition but what if it's a
block of statements right and it this
could arbitrarily inflate your coverage
measure right so there's really no I
mean this this is fundamentally
different to testing because you don't
have you don't know if your your
refrigeration does not run to completion
tests do so you don't know if you reach
the assert right
what does not deal with problem because
you might be Tommy oh I didn't use that
I don't know I didn't use incremental
search because that not that's not
efficient I use modular analyzes right
but the problem is you're probably using
approximation because you have infinite
state spaces you have state explosion
and you if you don't use server
approximation you're mala trigger
doesn't scale either so you have this
problem right and you have reached that
code which obviously is dead code and
you find it you're using pretty good
abstraction and you find a contour
example that's furious right because you
were not tracking the predicate but
again we have nonlinear arithmetic your
model checker gives up there and
internally it's absolutely ability tree
for instance would have that statement
in its representation right and well
should we consider it covered does it
count towards the coverage count or not
well I don't know there's a decisions
that people make and I made my decision
my decision it's basically this is sort
of a general framework this is not
actually tell you what any of the
previous examples should give you but
what I tell you is you need basically
some terminating execution right and why
some terminating excision because that's
a way to work around the problem of
verifying of checking whether you've
checked an assertion or not we have a
terminating execution well if your code
had any assertions you're gonna reach it
right the exercises the statement s
within an allies portion of T right so
that hold predicate I'm not telling you
what it is because it's it depends
heavily on what technique you're using
and I'm gonna talk about it in the next
slide for absolute visuality trees right
and then I ask that the the
terminating execution is actually safe
because if I found a counterexample
I shouldn't be computing coverage they
should be fixing the bug right so what
does it mean for apps our utility trees
well first of all why attribute ability
trees well because I was working with
that and it makes sense as a first step
but actually in our paper that we're
gonna get feedback tomorrow we talk
about some extensions of this for other
techniques sort of on a high level then
what what does it mean for our utility
tree as well we offload the whole has
been analyzed to the conditional model
checking predicate side right so it one
has something being analyzed well it's
been a lies if it reaches only nodes
outside the attribute ability reach
ability tree waitlist right so remember
we talked about the the trees we have
wait lists which correspond to stuff
that hasn't been exported yet if you
reach one of those well then it means
that you've gone outside the LS space
right if you haven't reached one of
those then you remain within the analyze
portion no no I didn't explain that part
so what we have is some terminating
execution T we have P which is a prefix
right and it's an analyze prefix so it
remains within the the attribute ility
tree and the statement is within the
prefix of the of the terminating
execution so this kind of raises the bar
a little bit for for verification
techniques because you know not only
have to have it within your structure
your internal representation but it also
has to be part of a feasible execution
and that's right this is I know it was
anyway so research questions is this a
kind of producer reasonable under
approximation of this within the
original Beautification time again why
do I have to under proximate it why
don't i compute the exact coverage well
because that's probably not computable
but I mean I really just again just time
out you don't know how many system
executions we have anyway so we present
property I mean kind of you need to it
depends on whether you have system
executions or not if you have
terminating executions you can just
check how much of that you cover and
that's one of the use cases that we that
we consider but that would be an unfair
comparison because that would be like oh
I can put it on the firewall but you
need to have those distant executions so
that you have to pay that cost at some
point so yeah sort of those system
executions yeah so what I have is a
terminating extinction tea I need I need
I need serve a witness that this is an
actual system execution that is not just
made-up state space so anyway so that's
one of the research questions and then
the other one is well but do model
checkers actually cover any code because
nobody checked so so what we do is
ideally we would want to write manual
tests and compare the coverage of that
with our multi-core coverage but there's
that's kind of like apple and oranges
like how do you compare the effort and
to go in for both things so we do is
compare it with against the automatic
test generation tool like clean here the
architecture same cases before we have a
code then we have the software male that
produces the assumption of talent and
that's it can that's the condition side
that conditional Maul checking talked
about then we have this whole pipeline
and then it's a loop right we have on
the left on the far left we generate a
specification that captures the sort of
properties that the terminating
execution will have then that
specification is fed into another
software model checker it could be a
different one and that several model
checker produces those safe terminating
executions that might have additional
properties or not and then we take those
safe terminating executions and we check
how those executions concert are covered
by the by the condition side right then
we update the coverage statistics then
we feed those back to the specification
why do we have that feedback loop
because in for instance CPA checker now
you can give it as
that tells you okay I want to cover this
one line in particular so every every
terminating excision that we generate is
the terminating execution that increases
the coverage which might not be case no
I mean if you if you produce a few
berries above our counter example your
report the bug which could happen it
actually does it's in the evaluation so
what do we do
same instances I think it has two modes
I think it has to do traversal at the
same time and it does round-robin I
don't really know the details of that
but anyway yeah Ackley would not will
not give up if it finds an insertion and
will continue producing test cases it
doesn't really care it will report them
but it will continue producing test
cases so we use the same instances phase
one is the same thing and phase two for
those with inconclusive results we can
put the coverage and we create a test
suite using Klee and we duplicate the
time spent right because well we're not
just verifying but we're also competing
coverage so CLE to be fair has double
the time so do we produce a reasonable
approximation within the original
verification time well let's look at the
technique separately so we have valley
analysis and I should have yeah this is
the wrong way of showing this but right
so for five of the instances we produce
an under approximation that is between
40 and 87 percent of the over
approximation let me talk about what the
over approximation is so CPA checker
already produces a coverage statistic
but how does it produce it well remember
those problems that I talked about at
the beginning that maybe you would have
a code that's not reachable and maybe
you would have perfect sees that would
trivially to assert false assertions
well that's how they produce it so it's
a very coarse over approximation but we
don't have the exact message so we use
that anyway so in this case it's not
ideal but I mean it's for more than half
the instances we produce reasonable
under approximation and then for two of
them we find bucks so then we give up on
the first
I mean the so only for two instances we
don't really produce anything useful
then for a lady leisa pretty good huh
then we don't produce anything for two
we don't produce output that's the
definition of nice because your time out
yes every time I was pretty name the
same result that CPA yeah no no see
patient always gives you know a person
is you guys it's a service if I see
another way to not be useful
approximation doesn't give you much
insight rate of coverage no but I mean
if you if you always get zero percent if
you let's get ten percent then it's
really bad if you get eighty seven
percent you're you know you're pretty
close to to the actual number then for
lazy pretty good abstraction then you've
got sixteen instances and then for
eleven of them you you give something
that's between 55 and a percent of the
over approximation for three of them
it's special cases basically one of them
is zero coverage because the exit is
actually unreachable
whereas CB a checker would report 267
lines of 388 covered right so that's how
bad how inflated the coverage could be
right for another one well you have a
bug phone so I mean it doesn't really
make sense to compute coverage and for
other one we get an abstract and final
error which is basically something that
we could work around I mean it's just we
chose to wrong technique maybe but it's
it's not absolutely unworkable and then
for two we produced it completely
asserts result which is nothing but then
how do we do compared to test case
generation well for fifteen hours twenty
three instances sovereign malting
coverage is out performs click coverage
and moreover for six out of 23 which is
more than 25 percent of the instances
we're a multiple of the coverage that
CLE produces and only for a couple
instances we we do get smaller coverage
that's so it's it's less than 80% of
what Klee covered so that's pretty much
the the conclusion soft off the coverage
part and I just like to summarize a
little bit of what I've talked about
doing to talk and talk a little bit
about future work which is I think kind
of interesting so base
key takeaways focus on inconclusive
results I think that's super interesting
having formal guarantees for the output
also super interesting so that users can
know what to expect about it then
building a proof of concept and
evaluating it can give you insights I
think that's interesting and that's
super event and you need to do it and
then for execution reports basically the
key contribution is just a the idea of
producing these safe combs and
exploration frontiers with concrete
guarantees that make it easy for your
users and then coverage the
contributions are the overview of the
challenges then a measure that can be
compared to test case generation that's
useful anyway future directions
short-term stronger guarantees for
coverage that'd be cool because there's
I have the intuition that there's
something about the breadth of a
verification attempt that we're not
capturing by using the same semantics
that you would have in test case
generation then improving usability of
reports is what you mentioned it's it's
long traces we have to pay attention to
that we have to find a formalization
that makes sense and that's still
intuitive for users encouragement
reports rather Jiggs we talked about
this a little bit in the coverage paper
that we wrote but it would be
interesting to implement it and actually
test it because we don't we don't know
what the coverage is for many things and
it would be interesting to know it then
technique and time limit recommendation
that would be basically now there's tons
of portfolio approaches to to sort of
statically choosing the best tool for a
certain instance and you use structural
features such as do you have loops do
you have floating-point do you have
pointer arithmetic stuff like that and
certain tools are better for this and
they're better for that but what if you
have a shortlist of four or five tools
and then run them in parallel and you do
like you can prioritize them but looking
at their intermediate results now that
we're getting is more insights into this
I think this is an obvious next step but
what about longer term well I'm
mentioning it again coverage
intermediate results for other
techniques and why am i mentioning it
again because I think we can take the
path backwards if we had a
representation that's actually shareable
and to between different techniques such
as coverage you could have much more
aggressive on unsound assumptions right
because it would make sense in that in
that context to to provide techniques
that can increase the coverage right
because this coverage is useful
I think this could lead to entirely new
family surf techniques that would make
sense in that context and that right now
it might be too specific and you might
not have a concrete use case for them
then a special case of this it's
Angelica purification right so you have
you you might have a very demonic
environment and what you're trying to do
is filter all those false positives
right and correct me if I'm saying
anything wrong because you're here but
why don't one of the things that you can
do is sort of make this two things work
together what if you could instead of
filtering out certain specifications why
if you could rank them using coverage as
a proxy for how reasonable or
unreasonable they are then well of
course we have to conduct large-scale
studies basically knowing whether the
results for test test case adequacy hold
for verification or if they're different
then building other types of reports
would certainly make sense what what
I've commented only is it's only good
for apps treatability trees but if
you're doing modular analysis it doesn't
all of that breaks down it's not really
useful then user studies because that
that's basically the only way to
validate that what we're doing makes any
sense and I think to integration is
basically the step forward to to get all
those ideas and making that vision that
I talked about at the beginning at least
closer to true so that's all that I had
to say and thank you very much for your
time all right whatever is there is
there an equivalent kind of effort
externally in the open source community
around using you know cuz I guess what
question ahead would be like what's
what's the path that you're you know
most immediate practical and use of this
I think the path doesn't look to the
most immediate practical use of this is
expecting that that integrating some of
these tools to them tonight II and the
obvious I mean I think the obvious place
to do that is Visual Studio because you
have to start with that's actually do
in some way right well that's that's
what I'm saying so you already have all
those tools integrated into Visual
Studio yeah you don't know at least that
I know of there's nothing like that what
there's there's sooner stuff and there's
static analysis integrated but it's more
like pattern matching certain smaller
things and it's not it's more
lightweight stuff then you do have some
concerted efforts into for instance like
the Linux driver verification effort but
all that it's usually using one or two
tools and it's very it's a very closed
community it's not I don't think that
Linux driver developers are using that I
think it's the other way around it's
just a closed like a more closed to
verification community trying to find
bugs and latex drivers yeah I know
pulling it's the pushing I mean it kind
of makes sense it's like if you're not
providing something that can give
consistent value why would your
developer use it I mean I don't think
there's there's on the tribulus we're
pretty clear on the Microsoft side of it
it does add value right it's you've been
using users only ten years right so I'm
just curious that even though we've been
doing this and you know shown that
actually adds I you know why or where
it's sort of this kind of effort is
actually taking place externally as far
as I know there's no there's no other
place in which it takes place I think
there's there's a few reasons why that's
the case I don't even talk about
applying but I think there's TV space
yeah sure I think is a significant
because it but also it's it's a plan I
mean so static are very far for instance
it's a you skate I mean - it's not you
can replicate that anywhere else because
you don't have outsider
companies writing I mean you don't have
a constant like you don't have a company
with control over Linux that can give
those yeah you know in the end a tool
chain around you know doing the mouse
technique right for a particular class
probably finding bugs that drivers would
become you know widely used it is you
know I think one of the things that
interesting Microsoft had a real problem
with drivers right yeah this issue like
you know the Machine crashes and you
blame them
right so we had a very strong incentive
to not have that happen but you think
the Linux TV would have the same proper
is that you know if when something
crashes in Linux it's like why well it's
a driver was bad right
yeah I've I don't think there's there's
significant pain points and it's the the
problem is basically your community is
different like if something crashes on
landings yeah I mean well I just
downloaded something that a random guy
wrote somewhere I didn't pay for that
saying I'll fix it I don't figure it out
I don't know I guess it's different for
a company and there's there's no really
great incentives for anyone to invest in
that basically so I think it's there's
just compelling reasons why that doesn't
happen outside Microsoft thank you very
much